[Applause]
that's the real part with it no I know
why you're happy it's summer and you
know it's summer when kids become just
like the president they have no class
really you had to think about that one
but this is the week when we found out I
guess this is a good news comparatively
that there is a place that most
Republicans will not follow this
precedent kidnapping children
molesting them in Alabama was okay but
you know you have to draw the line
somewhere ladies and gentlemen so summer
I said some Republican because 55% of
Republicans still support the separating
the family policy because of their
Family Values life begins at conception
and ends at the Rio Grande that's what
they believe
zero tolerance that's what that's when
Trump gives and that's what this crowd
wants zero tolerance for immigration and
also zero tolerance for knowing what the
hell they're doing because they don't I
can't remember all the lies that they
told just from the beginning of this
week this guy move so fast or only I can
fix it the only Congress can fix it Mike
so here's an executive order I fixed it
Ted Wright he signed an executive order
that revoked the policy that he started
he's the arsonist fireman
is the guy who congratulate himself for
saving the toddler in the pool that he
pushed in he have you ever seen a
president who more creates his own
crises I gotta call him president hold
my beer that's really what nobody would
be stupid enough sir to put babies in
prisons hold my beer for the
right-wingers not an easy policy to
defend but boy that is one big they
followed light Laura Ingraham said these
camps or jails or cages the kid we're at
quote essentially summer camp yes
they're doing arts and crafts that's
what they're doing well they're
stitching a bunk as handbags but it
looks like art
cages tents this summer camp I guess and
Frank was on a staycation it was really
Swift when Steve Doocy on Fox and
Friends went over the piano and started
playing hello mada Here I am in camp
tostada I mean but there is an uprising
there's a new lawsuit on behalf of the
migrant children that says that some of
the kids were drugged to control their
behavior so just like our public schools
[Applause]
but really there is a little bit of an
uprising people are realizing they can
fight back in different ways the
airlines a lot of the airlines have said
they're not going to transport children
that we're separated from their families
American airline said this is against
our corporate values and also you're
crying children are drowning out our
regular customers crying children
now you saw Melania went to visit the
detention center well that a camera in
there and all you heard was please help
I want to go home and finally one of the
kids said pulling put yourself together
lady
No so Melania you know this this is what
everyone's talking about money went sit
the kids were separated from their
families on a mission of mercy with a
jacket that had big letters on the back
that said I really don't care do you
I really don't care do you isn't it
great when our first ladies go through
their angsty teenage phase and of course
people said the optics of this when
you're on a mission of caring to wear
that jacket but in fairness come on when
has Melania ever known what's going on
behind her back
well you know the right-wing media said
this was big news because she only wore
the jacket on the plane getting on and
off not around the kids the coat was for
us with the kid she totally pretended to
care and trust me this is not the first
feeling she has faked